كتائب القسام الذراع العسكري لحركه حماس
صورا قالت انها للتصدي دفاعاتها الجويه
لطائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في سماء قطاع
غزه بصواريخ ارض جو فجرا اليوم
هذا وكانت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
قد شنت غارات على موقع لكتائب القسام
الذراع العسكريه لحركه حماس جنوب مدينه
غزه والحقت الغارات اضرارا بالموقع
المستهدف ومنازل وممتلكات المواطنين
المجاوره كما قصفت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
نقاط رصد تابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه قرب
الحدود الشرقيه لقطاع غزه وقال المتحدث
باسم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان طائرات
حربيه اغارت على موقع تحت الارض لحركه
حماس في مدينه غزه مخصص لانتاج ما وصفها
بالمواد الخام الصاروخيه وان الغارات رد
رد على صاروخ اطلق نحو المناطق
الاسرائيليه السبت الماضي